hybrid vehicles aren't all that popular
yet in Germany we want to see if we can
wet bakery on her fronts havens taste
for two models Vaughn says he thinks a
hybrid could be something for him it's
not far from his house to his business
so a hybrid will work he could charge it
in the front of the house and then shot
to nose will be I'm Noddin Olaf Laden
country first we'll introduce the Volvo
v60 as a plug-in hybrid from the outside
you can barely tell it apart from a
normal B 60 and the our design
emphasizes the hatchback sporty looks
the trunk has only 305 liters of space
rather than the 430 liters in the normal
v60 one reason is that the charging
cable which is stored under a hatch
takes up extra space a baker says he
likes the look of the exterior and that
the trunk is relatively big there's lots
of space for loading the car with baked
goods and cakes and its appearance is
nice too next we'll move on to one of
the world's best-selling cars the Toyota
Prius the plug-in is the flagship for
the whole Prius family 90 minutes
connected to a household electric socket
or all it takes to give the Japanese car
a full charge the trunk has 443 litres
of space that can be expanded to 1543
litres the charging cable has its own
underfloor storage area so what does
France think of our Asian hybrid he says
this car isn't really his thing the rear
end and the cargo area aren't really
suited to his needs but we're not
settling for that as the last word we're
sending our bakery owner out to test
drive the Prius plug-in hybrid together
the electric motor and internal
combustion engine deliver a total of 100
kilowatts Toyota says it's hybrid
requires only 2.1 liters of gasoline to
travel 100 kilometres at zero to one
hundred and ten point eight seconds
acceleration is a bit weak but emissions
of 49 grams of co2 per kilometre put the
Prius among the cleanest cars in its
class it has a range of 25 kilometres
running on electricity alone and a total
range of 1,200 when the gasoline engine
kicks in maximum speed running on
electricity is 85 kilometers an hour did
driving the prios remove some of
france's reservations
yawns the Baker says the car drove well
it's steady quiet and soft often for the
father yep
Fiat wish son now we'll compare we get
out of the Toyota and into the Volvo the
Toyota hybrid is a gasoline hybrid while
the car from Sweden is a diesel hybrid
we'll find out if that improves things
with a little test drive the diesel
hybrid produces up to 208 kilowatts of
power and burns just 1.8 liters of fuel
to travel 100 kilometers it's faster in
the Sprint getting to 100 kilometers an
hour in 6.1 seconds and running
emissions free on electricity alone the
v60 can go 50 kilometers together with
the diesel that climbs to 900 kilometers
the Volvo's maximum speed on electric
power is 120 kilometers an hour
what's art Baker convinced by the hybrid
diesel he says he's really happy with
his car for the most part though it was
a bit noisier to drive but it had more
zip - so both vehicles are worthy of
consideration until you address the
question of price the Toyota plug-in
hybrid sells for thirty six thousand six
hundred euros in Germany the volvo goes
for quite a bit more at fifty eight
thousand seven hundred euros
Fran says both cars cost too much and
then there are fuel and electricity
bills to consider and for the distances
he asked to drive it wouldn't be worth
it in a car just doesn't have that long
a service life Daanish lunin bill the
finnish zone outputs a coffin de'longhi
health and outline furnished we suspect
that as long as the German government
does not subsidize electromobility
as they do in other countries readiness
to invest in alternative drive systems
will remain low
you